budai tenichi 4 has officially had its
name revealed but surprise uh it's
actually called sparking zero let's
learn a little bit about the history of
the name real quick we actually have to
rewind all the way back to the 2.5d
budai games their original names in
Japan were actually just Dragon Ball Z
and when it was brought to the West they
changed the name because that was a bit
confusing so they went with budai
where's that name from well if you read
the Manga you'd know that the proper
name for the World Tournament is
actually the ten kichi Budokai then the
Dragon Ball Game moved to a new series
of games called Dragon Ball sparking
after the famous line in Dragon Ball Z's
opening theme song once again the name
was changed for the Western release this
time they went to piggyback off of the
huge success of the budai games and so
called them budai Tenkaichi even though
the two serieses were totally unrelated
and the name is backwards now Flash
Forward to today and I guess they aren't
worried about renaming the entire game
to appease the west and are sticking
with the Japanese title of sparking zero